이거는 네이버 카카오 두 회사의
영업이익을 합친 것보다 많은 수치를
합니다 가상
화폐 투자하는 분도 벌겠지만 사실
거래소가 제일 많이 벌죠
[음악]
내년에서 빌사남입니다 제가 오늘은
최근에 매각된 사례를 좀 설명
드리려고 하는데 좀 의미 있는 매각
사례인 거 같아요 그 테헤란로에 있는
대로변에 있는 건물인데
평당 8억 5천에 매각이 됐습니다
전에 이제 최고가 찍었던게 한
6억
8천 뭐이 정도의 매각이 됐었는데
선릉역 앞에 이번에는
삼성역 앞에
평당 8억 5천에 매입을 했습니다
최근에 등기가 넘어가서 누가
매입한지는 대략 예측은 하고 있었어요
제 영상 보면은
코인 거래소인 그 빗썸 지금 해당
건물은 그 삼성역 바로 앞에 있어요
저기 뒤에 보이시는 저 3층짜리 한
3 4층짜리 저 낡은 건물입니다
빗썸이 매입했던 건물 바로 옆에
건물입니다 그래서 아 이게 또 빗썸이
또 샀구나 이렇게 예측은 하고
있었는데 이번에
등기가 넘어가면서 좀 다루면 좋을 것
같아서
촬영하게 됐습니다 그래서 삼성역이
여기 있고
4번 출구 앞에
빌딩으로 되어 있습니다 그래서 아마이
두 필지를 멸실한 다음에
신축해서 사옥으로
쓸 것으로 좀 예상이 되고 일단
이거이 두 건물을 대출하는 없이
샀더라구요 전에 제가 말씀드렸던 그
업비트 두 나무가 매입했던 것도 한
3천억 정도인데 그것도
대출이 없구요
돈을 상당히 많이 벌었습니다 그때
이제 코인이
장이 좋을 때
돈을 많이 벌었어요 지금
2022년 기사인데 2021년이 되게
불장이었잖아요 그때
매출이 두 나무 같은 경우에는 3조
7천억 거기서 영업이익이 3조
2천억입니다 이거 진짜
엄청납니다 이거 영업이익률이 사실
인건비랑 뭐 임대료 이런 거만 빼면은
사실 나갈게 많이 없거든요 뭐 물건을
가져다 파는 것도 아니고 이거는
네이버 카카오 두 회사의 영업이익을
합친 것보다 많은 수치를 합니다
가상 화폐 투자하는 분도 벌겠지만
사실 거래소가 제일 많이 벌죠 예전에
금강러시 제가 말씀드렸던 거죠
곡괭이로 금 캐는 사람보다 거기서
곡괭이를 팔거나 아니면 청바지 파는
사람들이
돈을 더 벌었다 지금
빗썸도
매출이 그때 이제 21년도에 1조
정도 되는데 여기도 이제 영업이익률이
한 85%니까 거의 한 7,8000억
정도 될 거 같은데
엄청납니다 두 업체 다 3천억씩
삼성역 인근에
매입을 했습니다 두 나무가 매입한
거는 대지면적이 되게 커요 그래서 한
734평요
정도 되고
빗썸이 매입한 거 한 400평 정도
둘 다 3천억이잖아요
근데 가격만 보면은 비싸움이 되게
비싸게 산 거 아니야 생각을 할 수는
있는데
빗썸이 매입한 된 상업지고
구나무가 매입한 거는 노선
상업지입니다 상업지랑 3종이랑 같이
있어서
용적률을 가중평균에요
빗썸 건물보다는
용적률이 많이났습니다
지적 편집도로 봐도 이렇게
빨간색 부분만 800%고 여긴 다
이제 250%예요
디필즈까지
용적률 자체는 좀 차이가 많이 날
겁니다 비싼 건물이 되게 높을 거예요
그리고
뒤에 건물 여기 이제 도로가 접해
가지고 주차장은 아마 이제 뒤로 뺄
거 같습니다
빗썸 건물도 똑같아요 여기도 이렇게
들어와서 이쪽으로 주차장을
만들면요 전면이 또 다 살겠죠 제가
테헤란로 이번에 8억 5천
찍은 걸 보고 느끼는 건
어떤
식이든간에 뭐 지금
시기가 많이 안 좋긴 하지만
돈이 벌리면 이렇게
4억을 사거든요
4억을 산다라고 가정을 했을 때 뭔가
뭐 빌딩을 산다라고 가정을 했을 때이
사람들이
어디에 투자할까 이런 거를
약간 그 업체 생각으로 조금 생각을
해보면이 사람들도 돈 벌면 다 이쪽
주요 지역의 빌딩을 되게 사고 싶
하거든요 그리고 여기 뭐 개발 호재
이런 것도 많고
직원들 나중에 채용하거나 뭐 이럴
때도 이쪽 주요 지역에 무조건 있어야
되거든요
기업은 나중에 채용 관련해서도 되게
중요한 요소고 뭐 고객들이 왔을 때도
뭐 삼성역에 뭐 진짜 3000억 그
이상의 빌딩에 뭔가 사옥을 쓰고
있다라고 하면은 거기 이용하시는
분들도 되게 좀 안정감 이런게 또
들잖아요 그 현대차가 또 보면은 여기
진짜 10조
넘게 투자한 이유가 있다니까요 그래서
말씀드리고 싶은 건 뭐냐면이 업체들
그 시기에 되게 잘된 업체들이
돈이 생긴 다음에 빌딩을 산다 그러면
대부분 다 주요 지역이 빌딩을 삽니다
대출 안 받고 샀잖아요 두 업체다
심지어 두 나무는
강남역에도 샀어요
4,300억짜리 그것도 연면적당으로
치면은 거의 5천만원 가까이 됩니다
그런 업체들이
돈이 생기면 다 이쪽에 삽니다 그래서
제가 계속 영상에 말씀드리는게 주요
지역에 사야 된다
[음악]
결론은 주요 지역의 빌딩을 사자
돈이 몰리는데 사야지 주변에 계속
최고가 찍어주고 비싸게 팔려주고
해야지
덩달아서 같이 오르는 겁니다
용의 꼬리를 잡자 오늘 영상 여기까지
하고요
다음 시간에 또 뵙도록 하겠습니다
감사합니다